les prix sont bas dans le game bb oui
les baptêmes c'est notre fierté on fait
la messe avait trop de style on rajoute
du soin d'entendre team et où les rois
mages des temps modernes on a même des
snap de l'assemblée est proche de
l'hôtel obligé tu lui danse pour la teuf
on n'a pas fait voeu d'abstinence au
bénito d'emilie tout fait même des
baptêmes dans le tri au bénito béni
on envoie des lits au nom du père
numéro 10
nom du père
vous voulez qu'on fait c'est tout
mobilisent oui
en catéchines
je
g
tel fonds soit
m
c
mais ici comme jamais
et comme jamais baptisé comme jamais
une haie boutin estimé boutin katona
chapelle
katona chapelle
vous avez aimé
alors rendez vous le mardi 20 septembre
sur w9 à 20h55 pour d'autres clips et
d'autres sketch encore plus
extraordinaire c'est à dire à la fois
extraordinaire et magnifique des
sketches encore plus formidable
non tu n'as pas compris